hello guys and welcome back to the
channel I hope you've all noticed my
very significant aesthetic and stylish
goatee which I've begun rocking uh
coincidentally I tried entering a
playground the other day and a cop
wouldn't let me in for some reason I
don't really get that but anyways let's
get into the subject matter for today
which is going to be cash eviction
policies so similar to your evil
ex-girlfriend sometimes when you've got
too much of something that you don't
want to around you're going to have to
get rid of it the same is true for cash
data so let's talk about how we can do
so in today's episode episode all right
I got this long white fella out right
here and I may or may not be talking
about the apple pencil so today like I
mentioned we'll be talking about cash
eviction policies so the same applies
for caching on a single desktop computer
as well or just a normal CPU but
basically whenever we're talking about
caching we want to avoid cash misses
generally speaking in order to ensure
that we're using faster storage we're
probably using more expensive storage
for our caches and as a result we're
going to have less of it what that means
is that when we run out of data in our
cache and we want to put some new data
in there we're probably going to have to
evict some old data and so again this is
going to allow us to avoid misses
assuming that we do it in a smart way so
what would be one example of that well
for example let's say I am over here and
I'm trying to figure out how many views
I have and then we've got gorav senen a
former collaborator of mine asking how
many views he has and we're both hitting
this cach I might hit it first thus the
reason I have an entry in the cache but
then if gorov goes and asks for his data
he might actually clobber my entry
because perhaps we only have three
entries in the cache and then we would
have you know gorov with you know 100K
views and then now I go and ask again
and now my data is gone and Joe Rogan
and peie never even asked how many views
they had so who needed their data in the
cash so again we want to be smart about
when and why we get rid of our data so
let's talk about some eviction policies
that we can use to determine you know
what we actually get rid of in a cache
when we run out of space and how we
might actually go ahead and implement it
the first one is first in first out or
fifo so fifo as the name implies is
implemented using a queue so for example
if I wanted to go ahead and add a piece
of data to the cache that I'm going to
use in the future I would go and add it
to the head of the list right here and
then let's say you know gorov comes
along and he wants to add his own piece
of data so
gorav for 100k so he has 100K views in
his video he would add it at the end of
the link list and then as a result we
would find the current head over here so
it's this guy here head and then we
would just go and x that out and say now
the head is here and so that's pretty
easy to implement right we all know how
to use Q's assuming we've done a little
bit of data structures and algorithms
prep however there's a big issue with
that which is that when I am over here
rather and I eventually get my data
expired
if I want to keep accessing it and I've
been accessing it that entire time we
don't actually account for the fact that
I'm still interested in my data if I've
have accessed this thing a 100 different
times and eventually I get expired as
more pieces of data get added to the
cache well guess what I'm screwed out of
luck regardless of how often I'm using
the cach so what would be a more
intelligent method well one of them
might be lru or at least recently used
which actually goes ahead and takes into
account when the last time I accessed a
piece of data in the cache was and as a
result if I accessed it very recently
then we don't want to remove that but
rather we have a preference for removing
pieces of data that have not been
accessed in a long time so let's go
ahead and say something like this where
this is like
oldest and this is
newest and so again gorav is going to
come in and add a new piece of
data right gorov and so now we can add
it into our doubly linked list I'll
explain why we do that in a second and
then we would get rid of PewDiePie
because that is at the oldest end of
things so that's how we would do um a
new entry in the lru cache but the again
the unique thing about lru is that
entries that already exist have to be
moved around so for example let's say I
read my entry and now I want to move
that to the beginning of the list
basically I'd have to flip spots with
gorov to be put it in the newest section
over here and that right there is the
reason why we implement it this way
which is a hashmap plus a doubly link
list so you can see that the access
pattern would be okay I want to move
where Jordan is in the doubly link list
first I go to the map it tells me here's
the node for Jordan over here and then
now because it's a doubly link list I
can do the actual shifting around of the
nodes in O of one time because whatever
node it is that I'm taking I'm literally
just putting it at the head over here
hopefully that makes sense sorry if it
was a little bit poorly drawn out but
the point is you go to the hashmap you
find your node you move it to the head
of the link list that's o of one makes
life super easy that's why we're using a
doubly linked list right here to keep
time complexity nice and low and so lru
is relatively easy to implement which is
why it's commonly used in practice it
also just makes a lot of sense if I you
know access the value in the cache a
minute ago it doesn't matter if it's
been in there for a week I still want it
because I'm still active accessing it so
I shouldn't get rid of it another
possible alternative is lfu or least
frequently used so I'm not going to go
too deeply into the implementation of
something like this because in it of
itself it is a lead code hard problem
but the general gist is you would
actually want basically like two sets of
doubly link lists also with hashmaps and
each of those doubly link lists would
have a frequency so the frequency is
going to represent how many times that
cache entry has been accessed before so
you can see uh for the example of Jordan
and how many views he has on YouTube he
has 10 views and that cash entry has
been accessed eight times The Joe Rogan
entry has been accessed four times and
the PewDiePie entry has been accessed
six times so if we had to evict one of
these entries which one would it be it
would be the Joe Rogan entry because it
was least frequently used it's only been
used four times as opposed to the other
two more popular entries so again dou
link list of frequencies where it would
be like um you
know here are all the nodes that have
been accessed four times here are all
the nodes that have been accessed three
times blah blah blah blah blah and then
these and themselves are linked up and
then you know you might have one linked
to
six again look up the implementation
yourself I don't really want to make
this video 20 minutes long I think it
would defeat the purpose I don't think
anyone's going to ask you how to
implement this in a systems design
interview but if you are preparing for
dsna maybe it could come up so you never
know so what is the conclusion to this
relatively short video well basically
the answer is as per usual there is no
right answer for choosing a cash
eviction policy however there are
definitely wrong answers fifo probably
not as good as lru Lio which you would
Implement with a stack I really can't
think of a good reason to use random
eviction policies probably also pretty
bad though they do come with the
advantage that you don't actually have
to have any extra metadata about your
cache data so maybe if you're really
cramped for space doing things randomly
could potentially be useful but just
generally speaking you should know the
tradeoffs of these approaches a general
idea of how to implement them because at
least for lru it could definitely come
up in an interview and of course when
you ultimately want to be using them
which is going to depend on your use
case anyways guys I hope you enjoyed
this video let's keep those views up so
I don't have to sell footp picks and I
will see you in the next episode